der forschungsreaktor wendelstein 7-x in
greifswald hat einen neuen weltrekord
aufgestellt es wurde ein fusionsprodukt
erzeugt das so energiereich war wie
keine zuvor das heißt dass die
kombination aus jungen temperatur plasma
dichte und energie einschluss zeit die
höchste je erzeugte war oder
umgangssprachlich noch nie war die
kombination der drei eigenschaften des
plasmas aus temperatur dichte und dauer
in einen stellarator reaktor so hoch und
wieder rekord erreicht werden konnte und
wie es jetzt weitergeht in kriegs und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ein kraftwerk das durch eine kernfusion
unmengen an energie produzieren das
könnte die lösung aller energieprobleme
dieser erde sein das große vorbild die
sonne
der traum von forschungsteams weltweit
das kann von sie uns experiment
wendelstein 7-x in greifswald ist ein
heißer kandidat um neue spannende
erkenntnisse dazu zu liefern nach
umbauarbeiten wurde jetzt ein neuer
rekord aufgestellt wendelstein 7-x ist
ein versuchsreaktor der den bau eines
funktionierenden und eben energie
liefernden stellarator reaktors
ermöglichen soll
und es scheint als läuft hier alles
wirklich nach plan
dabei ist die sonne das natürliche
vorbild für die kernfusion hierbei
verschmelzen die atomkerne von
wasserstoff unter sehr hohem druck und
hoher temperatur miteinander
dabei entsteht helium und riesige mengen
an energie werden freigesetzt deswegen
wird die kernfusion als auch als die
neue primäre energiequelle gehandelt und
könnte tatsächlich co2 frei erneuerbare
energien ergänzen und sie ist dabei vor
allem viel ungefährlicher als die
aktuelle atom spaltung in
kernkraftwerken hier kann es zu einer
super gefährlichen kettenreaktion kommen
einem super-gau der unmengen an
radioaktiver strahlung freisetzt bei
einem fusionsreaktor kommt die reaktion
bei einem unfall dagegen direkt zum
erliegen und die radioaktiven stoffe die
entstehen besitzen eine halbwertzeit von
jahrzehnten und nicht von jahrmillionen
die kernfusion wäre ein
riesenfortschritt dabei ist der
separator reaktor etwas anders
konstruiert als der zuckermarkt typ der
jetzt mit dem etat in frankreich gebaut
wird bei beiden typen muss ein
magnetfeld das fusions plasma in einem
jahr in einem ring halten da es
millionen grad heiß darf es nicht mit
den wänden des reaktors in berührung
kommen beim töpfermarkt wird dazu im
plasma ein strom induziert und beim
stellarator wird das magnetfeld komplett
von außen erzeugt so muss der reaktor in
allerdings kompliziert verdrillt werden
was die konstruktion ungleich
schwieriger macht bei wendelstein 7-x
ist das gelungen und so sind dort alle
experimente auch bisher gelungen und
jetzt wurde im unterschied zur ersten
experimentier runde zwei
15 16 das plasma gefäß von wendelstein
7-x mit einer innenverkleidung
ausgerüstet kacheln aus graphit bedecken
jetzt die gefäßwände und machen höhere
temperaturen und längere plasma
entladung möglich wie diesen so
genannten die wärter lässt sich darüber
hinaus die reinheit und dichte des
plasmas regeln zitat die ersten
erfahrungen mit dem neuen band elementen
sind ausgesprochen positiv sagt thomas
ann petersen leiter des projektes waren
am ende der ersten kampagne puls dauern
von sechs sekunden zu erreichen sind nun
bis zu 26 sekunden lange platzenden
möglich dabei konnten bis zu 75
megajoule heizenergie in das plasma
eingespeist werden 18 mal mehr als in
der ersten betriebs runde ohne die
wörter auch die heizleistung konnte
erhöht werden eine voraussetzung für
eine hohe plasma dichte auf diese weise
wurde ein neuer weltrekord wert für das
sogenannte fusionsprodukt erreicht
dieses produkt aus ionen temperatur
plasma dichte und energie ein
schlusszeit das gibt an wie nah man den
reaktor werten für ein brennendes plasma
kommt bei rund 40 millionen radio und
temperatur und einer dichte von 0,8 mal
10 hoch 20 teilchen pro kubikmeter hat
wendelstein 7-x ein fusionsprodukt von
gut sechs mal 10 hoch 26 grad mal
sekunde pro kubikmeter erreicht
weltweiter steller rekord hammer zitat
dies ist ein für die größe der maschine
ausgezeichneter wert jetzt zudem unter
realistischen bedingungen das heißt bei
hoher temperatur der plasma ionen
erreicht wurde so sanders die erzielte
energie einschluss zeit ein maß für die
güte der wärmeisolation des magnetisch
eingeschlossenen placements deutet mit
beachtlichen 200 millisekunden darauf
hin dass die wendelstein 7-x
zugrundeliegende rechnerische
optimierung greift zitat das stimmt uns
für die weitere arbeit optimistisch
jetzt wird weiter experimentiert und im
herbst werden dann neue kacheln
eingebaut die jetzigen grafikkern des
die werthers werden durch
kohlenstofffaserverstärkte kohlenstoff
elemente ersetzt die zusätzlich wasser
gekühlt sind sie sollen bis zu 30
minuten lange entladungen
machen in denen überprüft werden kann ob
wendelstein 7-x seine optimierungs ziele
auch dauerhaft erfüllt wir halten euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr keine videos zu der entwicklung
in diesen bereichen zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte
abo boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein
video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von
mir noch vor allen andern vom neuesten
video täglich und garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
and media abonnieren da gibt es das
neueste aus der social media welt dafür
ihr klicken aber nicht die genau glocke
vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken kernfusion vor dem
durchbruch
bis dann bleibt dran